wakanda forever
so in the last few days we got the
very sad and i think for the vast
majority of people
very unexpected news of chadwick boseman
passing away he had been battling
cancer a colon cancer for four years and
this was
not something that was publicly known i
don't
know if you know none of his co-workers
know
knew or anything like that but it
certainly had never been made
known to the public so
for honestly the bulk of the filmography
he's known for he was
in the midst of fighting cancer and he
did
succumb to that fight now
i by no means am saying that the
entirety of
bozeman's legacy is black panther
that is however what i know him from and
it does seem to be what is
connecting the hardest for a lot of
people in terms of
feeling the loss a character like
t'challa
requires so much because not only do you
have to
be able to do all the things you expect
of a superhero you have to
be able to physically have that presence
and have that certain amount of charisma
but you've all
on top of that if you're going to do
t'challa you have to exude
royalty that's regal
sense if that's going to sell and he had
all that he had
every ounce of what he needed to pull
that part off
he was fantastic and we sadly won't get
to see him in the part again
and i hope people won't think it
ghoulish
that i'm going to address
this character but the thing is i don't
i feel ill-equipped to try and
offer a proper tribute to the man
i i wish i could i don't feel like i can
but i can talk about the character that
is in many ways his legacy
and what will happen with black panther
now
because to my way of thinking there are
basically four
options uh open to marvel
well i suppose technically there's five
but the one i'm not giving any
consideration to is the possibility that
they
do no more black panther stuff in any
way whatsoever
and just don't bring it up there's no
way
that that happens black panther made a
billion dollars
it was nominated for oscars it it was
important to a lot of people they're not
just gonna
have that vanish so i'm gonna go through
these
in not in the order that i think is most
uh you know least to most likely to
happen or anything like that but rather
the order
in in the order of how much i would like
it to be the way to deal with it
starting with the one that i want them
to do the least
going up to what i personally think
would be the best way to move forward
at this point but
like i i have no insider knowledge i
don't know how likely any of these are
although i think the one i'm putting at
the bottom
is pretty unlikely but let's go through
these
the first option because we know the
technology now exists
is to bring him back through a body
double and cgi
like they did with peter cushing uh
playing grandma
tarkin in rogue one and how they did
with some of general leia's
scenes after carrie fisher passed for
um the rise of sky walker
i think this is pretty unlikely for a
couple of reasons the first is
in both of those cases it was a it was a
supporting character
an important supporting character
especially in the case of leia
a character with a lot of legacy that
people cared about but
not the lead of the story that's the
first problem
the other is i think it would feel
far more
inappropriately morbid and
disrespectful than i think it did in
either of those cases and some people
have had their arguments as to whether
what happened in those two other
instances was disrespectful or not that
is a conversation that has come
up but i think the reason it was by and
large
by the mainstream given a pass in those
two instances
was a peter cushing had been gone for a
very long time and that was
a novelty effectively that was like whoa
they could do that
assuming the effect worked for you and
then with
carrie fisher we knew she was going to
be in this movie and
while they did do some recreation they
did also pull existing footage
so that she was appearing in the film
at some point so that it wasn't all
this recreation and it still felt like
her
at least for part of it so there were
some balancing acts and neither is the
case
with chadwick boseman not to mention the
fact that i think
i think the wound is going to be too
fresh and one could argue that that was
the case with leia as well but again
between her being a supporting character
and there being some footage for them to
use
in that i think eased that a little bit
neither is the case here i think the
technology exists
that they could do it i think nobody
wants them to do it and i don't think
they're foolish enough to try
second option is to recast the part of
t'challa
now the marvel films have recast before
a couple of times they recast rhodey
war machine they recast bruce banner the
hulk
but the thing is the circumstances are
very different
in those instances it was disputes over
payment over
creative control or just not wanting to
come back
there was no tragedy underlying
those recastings and
one could make a stronger case for this
it's certainly not as
ghoulish as you know
resurrecting chadwick boseman through
cgi
but i don't think it's a it's a job i
wouldn't envy any actor
to take because
everyone's everyone's going to compare
them
and if they don't deliver
what people feel like chad mcchadwick
boseman would have delivered
then it's gonna get knocked and even if
it does
it's just gonna remind people of what
they lost so i think
that in this specific instance is a bad
idea i'm not
always against recasting
i i'm iffy on it i'm very um situational
on that i don't have a blanket statement
on it but i'm not
always against it in this case i don't
think
it's going to go well and i also again
think that
it's going to just be it's going to read
as disrespectful it's going to read it
it's going to read not as we're trying
to honor the legacy it's going to read
as
we need to keep making money with this
character so hell with it
so that gives us two more options
the first is have the character
die in universe now
they may or may not decide to actually
depict that again there's a risk of
coming across as
ghoulish for doing so but
if they in some way acknowledge so that
there can be
you know uh something
in universe to give us a sense of the
loss
of the absence whether it's a funeral
scene whether it is just
going over the impact on
various other characters and
acknowledging it and then sort of
moving away from that corner of
marvel and and
sort of letting that basically letting
wakanda mourn
that's an option but i think there's a
modification of that which is the last
option i think this is the best one
for a number of reasons i think it's
going to
feel the most organic to the situation
that we
very unfortunately find ourselves in and
there's also some
precedent and some basis in the source
material to do this
and that is to have shuri
take over the role of the black panther
she's actually done it in the comics
and i don't i don't
know if to if t'challa has ever died
in the comics but he has gone missing
so there are also instances in the
comics one of which
um my partner liz and i actually did a
review on on our
podcast stuff like a girl we did a
review of the first volume of shuri
which deals with black panther
t'challa being lost and not being there
and she has to try and figure out
how to a get him back which wouldn't be
the case here
but also like run help run the country
in his absence
i think that's their best option because
they benefit from shuri being an
established character
a character with very close ties to
t'challa
and they had wonderful amazing chemistry
i think she could probably do a
phenomenal job bringing across that
sense of loss the weight
of trying to take on that mantle
probably some reluctance
at doing it i think the best thing for
them to do
is to
have in universe t'challa is dead
and it's the
what i don't envy them is figuring out
how to do that
because and i'm not even going to try
and figure that out because
options are you could do something big
and spectacular basically having the cgi
suit where so you don't have to you know
recreate
his face you just basically have a stunt
double
you know get blown up or something like
that but that
feels very unceremonious
and for my part i kind of would prefer
that we just find out
that he that something happened that
he's gone
and actually you know what
i am going to make a suggestion
have him die of cancer
that for all wakanda's
technology for everything they can do
nobody lives forever
have it feel as sudden
in the universe as it did in real life
i'm sorry i um i didn't expect to get
choked up
i mean part of this
i've had family members go
from cancer and
it can be very quick at least
for your knowledge of it especially if
they're private people
and i feel like whenever cancer gets
depicted in something like
a superhero universe it's very drawn out
i think they have an opportunity to
acknowledge
the other side where it feels like it
came out of nowhere
i think that would be the best way to do
it have it
that he passed away between films
open with a funeral and have black
panther 2
be about shuri
trying to live up to his legacy
which would have a meta function because
that is what the film
would be trying to do in his absence
and i think that would be the most
respectful way to keep
the franchise going
into the future
uh it feels really wrong uh and weird
for me to do
my usual list of plugs if you care
there's links in the description i'm
leaving it at that
chadwick boseman was gone too soon
i did not know him
but i know his work i know
his legacy
and i
hope that he is even better remembered
by those who knew him than those of us
who
only got to watch him on the screen and
somehow still felt connected to it
thank you for watching
go hug your family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you